[Music]
the frantic search for 12 young soccer
players and their coach trapped in a
cave complex in Thailand is in its sixth
day the international rescue effort is
focused on caverns in Schenck
rai north of Bangkok a team from the US
military is on the scene the boy's
vanished Saturday when they went
exploring after a soccer game but has
Howard Johnson from our partners at the
BBC reports rescuers have a new reason
for hope
search-and-rescue teams have been
galvanized here today by the improved
weather conditions it's been raining a
lot over the last few days but today the
weather has held what we've seen is a
three pronged approach down behind me
they're been pumping water out of the
cave complex and also a u.s. Navy diving
team has been exploring the caverns and
caves beneath the ground here looking
for the boys trying to find than in this
murky water that has flooded the caves
down there they're part of a 30 strong
US Armed Forces team that I hear and
some of them are also in the hills above
us exploring looking for fissures or
shafts or chimneys to try and rappel
down to try and find the boys that way
now also the type I'm Minister came here
today and took a tour around this camp
he spent more than an hour meeting
search and rescue teams but also spoke
to the relatives of the 13 missing and
he brought a message from the Thai king
and that was that the country would put
all its resources behind finding these
boys Howard Johnson BBC News for CBS
News in Thailand
hopefully the Navy can help bring a
miracle to those boys and their families